now this is an interesting phenomenon
person a competes for something really
big and then comes up short
now in this hypothetical contest only of
course one side wins and person a is on
the losing side and yet after suffering
a defeat person a emerges more arrogant
and more self-assured than ever before
proclaiming that had certain things just
happened differently he or she indeed
would have won and in person a we see
very little introspection zero humility
and frankly zero logic now perhaps most
disturbing in this scenario is when
person a tries to use his or her loss as
a selling point now for people in
particular who fit the mold in recent
weeks come to mind first up
Tallahassee mayor Andrew Gilliam
remember he lost his bid to be governor
of Florida now he couldn't beat Ron
DeSantis but now he fancies himself as
the great Trump slayer of Florida we are
going to commit ourselves to registering
and engaging 1 million voters between
now and 2020 s presidential election we
can deny Donald Trump a second term this
isnt the sexy work I gotta admit I'm
sure it's probably more fun for some of
those out there running for president
this is the hard work of democracy now
remember he could be running for
president you know but he's decided to
do the really hard stuff like I have a
question why should the Democrats listen
to him on anything he's a loser
why should anyone listen to him well
I'll tell you why because he's a
self-appointed spokesman for the loser
grievance culture that we've developed
here and without a compliant media
working hand in glove with these losers
elevating their message their statue
Sacher that well the losers wouldn't
feel so emboldened but boy do they now
consider arrogant loser number 2 Stacey
Abrams who lost her race for governor to
Brian camp in Georgia now remember
though she didn't lose they took it from
her
citizens try to exercise their
constitutional rights and were still
denied the ability to elect their
leaders under the watch of the now
former secretary of state democracy
failed Georgia so let's be clear this is
not a speech of concession okay so she
doesn't concede that's gracious and
she's never once been called out for her
shameless racial fear-mongering she
became a statewide official and may have
a future at some point again in politics
but she acts like she owns the entire
Democrat field for 2020 now what am I
talking about she scoffs at the notion
pushed by the nascent Biden campaign of
being Uncle Joe's vice presidential
running mate I think you don't run for
second place I'm going to enter a
primary then I'm going to enter a
primary and if I don't another primary
my job is to make certain that the best
Democrat becomes the nominee and whoever
wins the primary that we make certain
that person gets elected in 2020 thanks
to the primary hello you lost the
governor's race having asked you and
your opponent made history spending more
than a hundred million dollars on a
governor's race and you still couldn't
pull out a victory I mean it happens but
you think you call the shots running in
a primary to be vice president is very
different than someone who has been
elected by the party to be the nominee
I'm asking you to serve as a partner
right and I am open to all options how
amazing know what's what now I'll bet
she's open to all options yeah well then
there is our third loser bethe O'Rourke
now he's treated like the crown prince
of Texas despite suffering a significant
defeat at the hands of Ted Cruz in the
Texas Senate race remember he had the
whole landscape of the media behind him
spent all this money but he has issues
grasping reality you have a president
from my opinion beyond the shadow of a
doubt sought to however ham handedly
colluding with the Russian government a
foreign power to undermine and influence
elections now that was Saturday cuckoo
for cocoa puffs all right good good luck
advancing the collusion narrative now
Robert Francis all right in our last
loser trying to claim victory is just e
Smollett now he faked a hate crime sent
Chicago PD in two weeks of
investigations took up oxygen in the
national conversation and he likely
frightened minorities already concerned
about the racial atmosphere in America
his actions and the follow up were
utterly despicable but he's been taught
to win by doing what while playing the
victim of course which is what he did on
Tuesday I've been truthful and
consistent on every single level since
day one I would not be my mother's son
if I was capable of one drop of what I
was been accused of this has been an
incredibly difficult time well his
lawyer goes on to leave open the
possibility that Jesse would try perhaps
to collect money in a lawsuit against
Chicago PD we're weighing our options
now for Jesse what's really important is
he really just wants his career and his
life back again he did not ask for any
of this he was a victim of a crime at
some point it can lawyers be sanctioned
for just saying something that's
blatantly false on national television
and what does the n-double-a-cp do to
reward criminal behavior well looser
behavior well of course they nominate
him for a none NWA CP award of course I
hope he's here I hope he's here and I
hope he wins I hope everyone wins
it's a big event and you know I hope I'm
glad everything has worked out for him
now here's what's happening there is
this impulse to shower losers with
accolades and importance when the losers
are anti-trump if you're Pro Trump and
you lose you just have to get over it
and get out of the way accept the
results not so on the other side and
Hollywood the news media print
journalists if you're anti Trump will
work overtime
to rewrite your narrative for you now
remember in home alone
remember when Kevin McCallister took on
the bad guys okay kid give it to me
[Music]
[Applause]
directive okay but it was never the
fault of the Wet Bandits the blame was
solely on the poor kid whose parents
left him home alone my friends if you
want to remake America from soup to nuts
or robbed some houses around
Christmastime
well you don't have time for
recuperating or changing your technique
instead what do you do you double down
on failure you act like you won big you
just hit the lotto and you blame your
loss on someone else very very mature
no other profession treats losers this
way that I can think of but in politics
reality is often suspended you don't
deserve anything now right we were
taught that you need to earn it all
those parents who bribed their kids way
into college thought their kids deserve
to go to Yale or USC or Wake Forest for
Stanford it's just that the system was
screwed up so they decided to game the
system and ultimately the fraud was
discovered I think the American people
are sharper than the left gives them
credit for I don't think they'll like
all this radicalism nor the entitlement
mentality that seems to be infecting all
races all ethnicities today folks want
basic fairness basic standards of
decency common sense not fanatical
efforts to deconstruct America and
reconstruct her into what Teddy
Roosevelt called the polyglot boarding
house being a loser doesn't mean of
course you can't win again not saying
that Reagan showed us that he lost in 76
came back in 1980 the rest is history
but it also doesn't mean that you should
expect the rest of us to bow down at
your every word just because you say
them with enough breathless indignation
about how much you don't like Donald
Trump get up brush yourself off and try
again but you have to earn respect to
win the votes
you're only gonna do that by making a
persuasive argument not by hardly
assuming that victory is going to be
yours just because you showed up and you
lost the first time and that's the angle
[Music]